[Musique]
oui mais prépare notamment l'inde depuis
sept semaines
je veux parler de la déclaration de
monsieur legault qui a fait qu'il ya
quelques semaines comme quoi il avait
une arrière arrière arrière arrière
grand mère qui était autochtone bien sûr
il a eu de la misère à la nommer je sais
pas s'il savait c'est algonquine
anishinabeg pourquoi est ce que je veux
revenir sur ça c'est que de plus en plus
ce discours a vraiment bien d'avant et
quand ces mêmes utilisés par notre
robinet faut qu'on en parle
césaire l'autre et son arrêt n'a rien à
la haye à cocoon pourquoi est ce que ces
problématiques de pouvoir toujours
vouloir sortir son ancêtre qui était
autochtone pour pouvoir parler soit de
racisme discrimination pour dire le
droit
pourquoi est ce que c'est le non jeu qui
est très difficile aussi bien au sein
même des communautés faut pas oublier
qu'on a eu beaucoup de pression sont le
rôle des femmes comme grosse maîtrise de
la culture transmetteur de l'identité
autochtone aussi jusqu'à 85 la loi sur
les indiens abolition l'identité
indienne des femmes si elles se marier
avec un non autochtone donc quand la loi
a changé on a vu au ciné son appel ces
craintes et un ca de re donner des
droits aux femmes qui avaient perdu par
le passé justin morneau identité parce
qu'elle avait mariés à des personnes qui
étaient non autochtone et qu'elle avait
été même exclu de la communauté avait dû
vivre en grande réserve puisque la
réserve s'est réservé pour dézinguer
et quand tu n'es plus une indienne eh
bien tu ne peux plus bling sur la
réserve salaire n'est pas énorme sur
notre histoire a un impact franchement
quand je rentre traumatique parce que il
des instances par an
comme à mon expérience personnelle mes
parents se sont jamais mariés parce que
mon père justement voulais pas que ma
mère perd le droit d'aller vivre avec sa
famille ou de retourner dans sa
communauté ou que nous mêmes nous
perdions le financités en point que
premièrement
juste par le mariage donc dans une
société beaucoup plus conservatrice
je vous peut imaginer l'effet que ça
l'oeil mais utiliser son arrière grand
mère pour dire des déclarations comme
quoi le racisme systémique n'existe pas
ou pour dire que j'ai des droits j'ai
des droits je suis autochtone finalement
on est tous autochtone ça ne l'est pas
vraiment destructeurs par rapport au
titre et à l'identité parce que le titre
c'est quand même un aspect de la loi sur
les indiens aspects du droit c'est
presque un aspect légal mais l'identité
autochtone est beaucoup plus complexe qu
uniquement la loi sur les indiens ou les
droits ancestraux qui sont reconnus par
le gouvernement canadien
l'identité des programmations c'est
quand même rien comme un héros par des
responsabilités par rapport au dérisoire
une connexion au territoire aussi et là
on doit en plus se réparer la
déconnexion forcée du territoire de
beaucoup de femmes et d'enfants soit à
travers les pensionnats soit on
travaille justement la loi sur les
indiens ou même par rapport aux sixties
groupe alrov des années 60 où vous
mettez les enfants dans des familles
d'accueil
alors vous comprenez on déconnecte et on
reconnaît des gens qui ne l'ont poche
n'ont pas choisi de l'être
cependant dans les dernières ma dernière
décennie beaucoup beaucoup de gens ont
commencé à sortir leurs arrières
arrières cinquième génération cette
génération d'allemands qui s'appelait la
sauvagerie est ce que je peux même pas
nommé c'est trop compliqué imaginé
entendre quand vous êtes et qu'une
prolongation qui a passé soit sa vie à
devoir se reconnecter à sa culture
parce que justement la colonisation est
venue donner un impact ou quand même que
vous êtes une des premières nations qui
reçoit du racisme habituels ou non vos
10 du racisme ordinaire turcs ont vécu
dans la rue pays traite des charges
caoutchouc et ou du racisme
institutionnalisé qu'on va accéder à des
services publics
et là quelqu'un qui sort son arrière
grand mère pour pouvoir de faire tout
ton expérience de vie pour prendre et
faire aussi l'importance du lien
communautaire et ça se voit beaucoup
quand
les personnes veulent retrouver leurs
ancêtres des programmations ou des
enceintes autochtone pour pouvoir clamer
des droits ancestraux des droits de
chasse des droits de pêche des droits à
bâtir un cadenas sur un territoire donné
mais qui n'ont aucune communication
connexions avec leur communauté et ont
perdu devient totalement donc c'est
extrêmement difficile de pouvoir
médecins de l'avant parce qu'après on va
se dire mais là vous n'êtes pas contents
qu'on célèbre nos origines des
présentations non on est très très très
content les gens célèbres principe qui
date d'octobre nous appuient deviennent
des avis cependant ce qui est vraiment
dérangeant c'est quand on sort les sky
est de son arrière grand mère pour
pouvoir le vendre ou pouvoir l'échanger
contre un le droit de faire des choses
qui sont vraiment déconnecté de la
communauté où la pratique traditionnelle
de ta propre nation alors c'est un sujet
qui m'a extrêmement difficile parce que
ça touche à l'identité et on sait que
québec une entité est extrêmement
sensible comme sujet ça va parler aussi
d'une déconnexion et ça va parler d'un
besoin de décoloniser
et voilà pourquoi je porte ce bougies
aujourd'hui d'économiser le concept de
l'identité indienne autochtone les
programmations et nous et d'en faire un
concept qui appartient encore nation et
pas un concept qui est gérée par la loi
sur les indiens et gérées par la cour
suprême du canada est utilisé comme un
espèce de drapeaux pour acquérir
certains endroits qui sont portées par
les communautés de penne misère depuis
une dernière 550 alors c'est vraiment
difficile d'entendre ce discours le mais
c'est pas difficile d'entendre quelqu'un
qui est fiable dans son arrêt renard qui
a pris le nom de son mari omar qui coûte
son histoire comme moi j'aime beaucoup
savoir que dans l'histoire de mon nom il
ya quelqu'un qui vient de l'ecosse ce
n'est pas une histoire fantastique au
niveau personnel de la famille mexicaine
ne savons que j'ai une connexion gsm et
poster l'école sous d'irlande par le nom
marlène qui est un arrière arrière
arrière cours ailleurs des bois qui est
venu au canada et qui repartira mais
est-ce que je vais aller clar mais les
highlands en écosse
est-ce que je vais aller demander des
droits à l'ecosse non mais j'avais
connecté au niveau humain par rapport à
cette identité
je vais m'y intéresser et c'est ça qui
est vraiment agréable pour une
communauté d'acteurs d'entendre et de
voir cette connexion se lier cette
relation mais faut pas oublier que cette
relation le ciel était déconnecté d'une
façon volontaire ou d'une façon
historiquement ou est ce que le fait
plus de relations avec la communauté
québécoise qu'avec la communautés des
premières nations
eh bien il a une problématique si tu
déclares mais des droits qui sont portés
en communauté des responsabilités qui
viennent avec que tu ne porteras patois
avec la communauté
donc c'est très large et très difficile
c'est très sensible et très polémique
on reste on entend beaucoup plus parler
j'espère que monsieur legault vous
connecter avec la responsabilité de sa
communauté et de son arrière arrière
arrière arrière comme pour pouvoir
reconnaître la cécité et pouvoir
supporter les communautés de façon
adéquate puisque il semblerait qu il
fait partie du nombre
je vous soumets semaine n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo et s'est pas passé
des commentaires construction s'il vous
plaît et je souhaite une belle semaine